[Musica]
beh allora né in alto vertiginosamente
in alto sulla gabbia più alta del pecore
sapete cosa il palco e la nave è un
personaggio anche lei anche il palco è
un personaggio alla nave sulla quale
capitano a cal
il suo equipaggio vanno a caccia di
capodogli in particolare vanno a caccia
di moby dick
allora lassù in alto ismael che è il è
l'io narrante di questo romanzo
personaggio narratore che dietro il
quale si nasconde a herman melville
naturalmente ben ricevo ismael affronta
per la prima volta la sua esperienza di
vedetta fa la vedetta lassù in alto
sotto di lui il pe code minuscolo una
specie di modellino non ave in miniatura
e intorno a lui si spalancano e nuvole
c'è orizzonte l'oceano
lui dice di se stesso di non avere
nessun talento per fare la vedetta
questo dipende dal fatto che non fissa
lo ri non scruta non non osserva
attentamente ha piuttosto il suo sguardo
è uno sguardo contemplativo contempla e
è uno sguardo svagato
trasognato si lascia cullare dal rollio
della nave e ben presto il suo io
cosciente cede e come se cedesse alla
seduzione dei venti e della salsedine e
della luce che appunto di questa visto
rollio costante e piano piano il suo io
cosciente si scioglie di veicolo
svanisce e io preferisco dire che si
risolve si risolve nella totalità degli
elementi che in quel momento lo circonda
lui non è più lui ma ha qualche cosa che
fluisce insieme all'oceano insieme alle
onde insieme alle nuvole insieme alla
totalità della natura e dei suoi
elementi
questo è un modello di espansione del
bio bio esce da se stesso le barriere
che lo circondano e lo definiscono si
abbattono e si espande si dilata
nell'universo
questa è l'esperienza che is mine
racconta n'è un'altra si una esperienza
e statica di questo tipo ed è quando lo
stesso ismael affonda le mani
in una vasta pira di sperma cede che è
l'olio prezioso che si trova nel capo
della balena nel capo a pò d'olio salute
del capo d'olio che il capo è pieno di
olio ed è quello gli oli di balena quel
grasso di balena è naturalmente
l'oggetto prezioso della caccia alla
balena bene a contatto con l'aria lo
sperma ceti si è condensato si è
cristallizzato i marinai devono col
cuore ma li rubano le dita devono
stemperarlo a stringerlo e renderlo di
nuovo fruito ecco allora che affondano
le mani e così senza pensare
automaticamente fanno questo lavoro sono
seduti in cerchio ismail raccontando
dice che le sue dita facendo quel lavoro
cominciano aspira rarsi e se per nella
traduzione meravigliosa di ottavio
fatica einaudi speer alarsi et semper
prendono vita propria le dita e non
soltanto strizzano i cristalli di sperma
cedi ma cominciano a cercare
inconsciamente le dita degli altri
marinai e stringono per maceti e dita e
mani umane e anche dice un momento di
oblio un momento in cui questo stringere
le mani forma un intreccio una catena
umana in cui l'io non è più lì ho chiuso
in se stesso ma si apre si intreccia con
tutte le altre presenze che sono intorno
e sono presenti diversissime perché non
c'è
melting pot più complesso più vario più
straordinario dell'equipaggio nel tackle
quindi altre esistenze altre
lontanissime provenienze di si
intrecciano con l'io semi cosciente o
quasi
non più cosciente di smart altra
esperienza di espansione del vino bio
abbatte i propri confini e si dilata va
in scena ed esce da se e confluisce
verso l'altro fluisce si fonde e si
confonde con l'altro ma alle spalle di
smile fisso sul cassero con la gamba
addosso di palena infilata dell'apposito
buco sta ritto come una statua di ferro
a cap
aqap rappresenta l'opposto sotto il
profilo morale h non si scioglie e
rigido come una statua di ferro e
ribadisce la sua volontà di traccia una
volontà rettilinea che non si spande ma
corre dritta verso lo scopo dritta come
se obbedisse ha un istinto profondo o a
un destino superiore
ecco anche lì c'è qualche cosa che
riguarda l'espansione perché perché aqap
altro né altri non è scusato che il
continuatore di quei padri pellegrini
puritani che fondarono la verità bianca
e pulita
come loro come loro discendenti anno si
sono sparsi per l'america hanno
conquistato l'america hanno attraversato
le praterie e hanno sterminato i bisonti
allo stesso modo verranno sterminato
anche i nativi per dire la verità non
allo stesso modo continua questa impresa
a cap
e poco importa se ad essere sterminati
adesso sono le balene
no invece degli esseri umani o del ecco
lui deve portare a termine la sua
impresa che come sapete anche una
vendetta perché moby dick di ha
strappato la gamma gamba al posto della
quale lui adesso porta un osso di balena
promemoria però per non dimenticare
quindi c'è espansione anche lì perché si
attraversano il mare si attraversano si
affrontano rotte oceaniche prima tutto
l'atlantico poi capo horn poi il
pacifico
poi verso il giappone sono imprese e
quelle di baleneria ai tempi del romanzo
siamo siamo alla metà dell'ottocento
il romanzo viene pubblicato nel 1851
imprese che possono durare anche 3 4
anni 34 anni di navigazione è un
espandersi anche quello ma qui
l'espansione diventa volontà di potenza
volontà di dominio volontà di incisione
come è stata l'espansione dell'europa
come è stata l'espansione dell'occidente
dal 1492 filo
a pochi anni fa dico poche anni fa
perché adesso io vedo l'occidente molto
contratto su se stesso e molto in difesa
c'è un bel libro di molinari direttore
della stampa intitolato l'occidente
sotto assedio non solo dalle forze di
trash anche alla cina eccetera non
guardate adesso questo momento di
transizione in cui la cina è così in
crisi ma rete che riprenderà la sua
corsa
ecco è questa è la scelta di frutta alla
quale non ci troviamo queste due
accezioni della parola espansione
l'accezione da cui viene fuori
espansionismo espansionismo e quindi poi
colonialismo e imperialismo e riduzione
in schiavitù dell'altro e rapina delle
risorse della terra
questa è una accezione che ha prevalso
nella storia della nostra civiltà e
dall'altra parte invece dall'altra parte
invece come vi dicevo la dilatazione
felice de lio la quale però ha un prezzo
bisogna che lo ceda
bisogna che dio rischi
la piccola morte rischi di sparire per
potersi lasciare invadere dall'oceano
lasciarsi invadere dal divino che lo
circonda lasciarsi invadere dal divino
di cui è parte
fin dal momento del suo concepimento
quell'espansione che ci fa diventare
tutt'uno con la totalità del vivente è
un'esperienza che vi auguro di provare
in qualsiasi modo perché è giusto che
ognuno di noi torni ad essere quello che
è cioè come diceva il nostro grande
ungaretti una docile
fibra dell'universo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
certo